disney plus has become a massive success
thanks largely in part to its almost
complete catalog of marvel cinematic
universe movies
as well as introductions of some
fantastic original series
now tom hiddleston is returning to the
mcu as loki
and he has everything we know about his
disney plus series
so far it's been almost two years since
the announcement of the loki series
which has dragged on forever as we've
awaited the highly anticipated project
for quite a while it looked like we'll
be getting the series debut on june 11th
in keeping with the tradition of
launching disney plus series on friday
in may of 2021 though star tom
hiddleston
announced that the six episode series
will actually debut june 9th
making it the first wednesday debut on
the streaming service
wednesdays are the new fridays for now
it doesn't look like disney plus will be
changing their episode drop times
so die hard fans in the united states
will have to continue to wake up early
or stay up late for the 3am eastern
premieres
regardless of the time loki will be the
show of the summer for sure
and if its disney plus predecessors are
any indication
it should be a massive hit for marvel
studios
will there be a second season maybe
deadline all but confirmed a loki season
2
when reporting on producer michael
waldron signing a new deal
with marvel studios waldron is the
executive producer on loki and will be
petting the script for the new star wars
film
that studio head kevin feige is
producing he's also expected to return
for season 2 of the disney plus series
as a part of his contract
this could also mean that initial
reports of a 12 episode loki series
were actually indicating 12 episodes
total spread out across
two seasons marvel studios producer nate
moore also seemed to confirm more
low-key adventures
as he explained in an interview with
slash film i think there's a lot of
storytelling in loki
that's really irreverent and clever and
cool but also lends itself to multiple
seasons
in a way where it's not a one-off in
other words while no one as straight-up
officially said there will be a loki
season 2
it's looking very likely and we can't
wait to watch your six episodes to get a
better understanding
of where the show could go a series
about loki just wouldn't work without
tom hiddleston
so we're happy to report that the
charming actor will be reprising his
role as a god of mischief
but when it comes to who will be
starring alongside him there are some
pretty stellar names on the cast list
including one beloved comedy star owen
wilson has been confirmed to be
portraying
m mobius a manager in the time variants
authority
in the comics mobius is a tva bureaucrat
in charge of taking care of time
and if you disrupt the proper flow he'll
make sure to throw the book at you
even if you're a member of a powerful
superhero team or an asgardian legend
as the case may be as for the series
from what we can tell by the trailer
mobius appears to be a major character
in loki he will be working alongside the
tricks to guard
to fix the timelines he interrupted when
stealing the tesseract
interestingly this isn't the first time
that hiddleston and wilson have acted
alongside each other
and in a project involving time travel
no less the two stars appeared together
in 2011's midnight in paris
which found wilson as a modern-day
tourist accidentally stumbling into
1920s paris
where he encounters hiddleston's f scott
fitzgerald
so who else is filling out the cast of
loki well it looks like goo goo and
batara will be playing a powerful member
of the time variance authority
known as judge ren slayer from the
trailers we can tell she's obviously a
force to be reckoned with
sitting behind a large imposing desk and
looking down on loki
and chances are good that judge ren
slayer is actually ravana renslayer
a character who hails from the 40th
century and is romantically linked with
kang the conqueror
a character who'll be showing up in
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania very
soon
loki will also feature erica coleman as
florence schaffner
if that name sounds familiar it's
because schaffner was a real-life flight
attendant
involved in the infamous db cooper
hijacking and
based on the trailers it looks like old
db might actually be everybody's
favorite trickster guard
we also know that one mi masaku will be
playing a heavily armored tva officer
and we see her escort loki through a
portal in one of the trailers
masaku will be joined by sasha lane who
also seems to be playing an armored tva
agent who will most likely be giving
loki a hard time
in march 2020 variety reported that
richard e grant most famous for his
roles in with nail and i
gosford park and can you ever forgive me
was joining the cast of loki
grant's role is still being kept under
wraps but we know that he'll show up in
at least one episode
there were no obvious appearances of
grant in any of the loki trailers or
sneak peeks
so we'll have to wait till the show
debuts on june 11th
to see what his mysterious character is
up to however some fans suspect he might
be showing up as an older version
of the titular tricks to god sophia di
martino has also been confirmed for loki
and the actress known for roles
in yesterday and into the badlands is
playing another mysterious role in the
mcu project
some redditors believe she's playing
either a female version of loki
or even the evil asgardian sorceress
known as enchantress
but neither have been confirmed at this
time if you're wondering about the
behind the scenes talent
michael waldron wrote all six episodes
of loki and he also serves as an
executive producer on the series
the show is directed by kate herron who
will also serve as an executive producer
alongside kevin feige and stephen
brassard fans of the mcu should be super
excited for this experienced creative
team
and some of the loki actors are paying
respect to those on the other side of
the camera
google and bartholo praised heron on her
mcu directorial debut
in an interview with the big ticket
podcast saying i feel like even though
you're dealing with this big universe
she still makes it feel very intimate
she just brings it back down to
character and moments and emotions
for almost two years we've speculated
about what the plot for loki could
entail
and in true marvel cinematic universe
fashion mum was the word on what the
series would be about
but with the release of trailers and
sneak peeks we have a better
understanding of what to expect from
loki this
june kevin feige confirmed at san diego
comic-con in 2019
that the series would take place
immediately after the trickster stole
the tesseract
in avengers end game the trailers have
confirmed that by making off with the
space stone
loki screwed up a whole bunch of
timelines and the series will watch him
fix these broken timelines while being
guided by the time variant's authority
unbelievable wherever you go it's just
death destruction the literal
ends of worlds from the trailers we saw
loki and mobius in pompeii
so we do know the pair will be traveling
back in time as far back as 79 a.d
what other eras loki might find himself
in remains a mystery
but he's also suspected to be on earth
somewhere in 1971
based on the db cooper hints in the
trailer loki appears to be the famous
hijacker who held a plane ransom for 200
thousand dollars
and disappeared via parachute never to
be seen again
mcu projects rely heavily on the source
material and loki will be no exception
and we can make our best guesses on
which comic issues the series will pull
from based on what we saw
in the trailers there definitely will be
inspiration from 2016's vote loki
which was a satire on the united states
presidential election of the same year
loki can be seen in the trailer wearing
a pin that saves vote loki
while others around him also don the
campaign accessory
and since the time variants authority
will play a major role in the show
we know several aspects will be pulled
from the comics regarding the
organization
the tva first appeared in thor issue 371
in 1986
and the group has had encounters with a
handful of famous marvel names
including the fantastic four kang the
conqueror and she hulk
characters we all know are showing up in
the mcu sooner
rather than later the marvel cinematic
universe has one giant web of
interconnecting plots
and you can expect loki to follow suit
it hasn't been confirmed at this time
but some believe tom hiddleston will
show up as loki
in the upcoming thor loving thunder film
with him ending back up with his brother
due to the events of the disney plus
series
since the mercurial villain is confirmed
to be traveling through time and
realities
he very well could return to the main
timeline on earth and space with his
brother
we also expect loki to connect to doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
which will delve heavily into alternate
realities that play a part in one
division
and possibly the upcoming spider-man no
way home
in an interview with bloomberg
businessweek kevin feige noted that the
events of loki and the doctor strange
sequel
will be connected doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
is set to premiere on march 25 2022
with thor love and thunder following on
may 6 2022
it's very possible loki shows up in the
doctor strange sequel
possibly running into steven strange or
the scarlet witch
in another reality if either helps bring
him back to the main timeline
it's likely the opening for loki to
waltz into the events of thor 4
like nothing had ever happened check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one